وسنعود مشاهدينا الى موضوع روسيا فالكسب
الحرب مع روسيا وحسمها الان اوكرانيا هي
بحاجه الى ثلاثه اسلحه بعد ان الحقت كيرف
سلسله من الهزائم الكبرى لموسكو مؤخرا
تقول مجله نيوز بيك الامريكيه اوكرانيا
تمتلك القدره والاراده لاخراج القوات
الروسيه من اراضيها والفوز لكنها حقيقه
تفتقر الى المعدات العسكريه اللازمه
لانهاء الحرب بسرعه خبراء عسكريون
بريطانيون اكدوا للمجال الامريكيه ان
تسليحه اوكرانيا بالدبابات والمدرعات
الثقيله من شانه ان يساعد بهزيمه روسيا
وجود هذه الدبابات والمدرعات يجب ان
يتزامن مع وجود اعداد كبيره من الجنود
وهذه العمليه تسمى التنقل المدرع اي ان
المركبات المدرعه والدبابات يجب ان تعمل
معا في عمليه مشتركه لانه في حال عملت هذه
الدبابات فريده ستكون عرضه للاستهداف من
قبل القوات الروسيه وهنا نتحدث عن الف
دبابه بالاضافه الى المركبات التي ستحمل
الجنود كي تنجح هذه العمليه الان ما هو
السلاح الثاني الذي تحتاج اليه كاف هو
صواريخ بعيده المدى التي طلبها
الاوكرانيون مثل مثلا اي تي اي سي ام اس
سيسمح للاوكرانيين بضرب شبه جزيره القرم
واخراج البحريه الروسيه منها سانتقل الان
الى ثالث الاسلحه فهو تسليح القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه وهو امر بالغ الاهميه لحسم
الحرب ايضا لماذا لانك ركزت في الاشهر
الماضيه على القوات البريه وايضا على
الدفاع الجوي ايضا على اكياس ان تختار بين
المقاتله الامريكيه من طراز اف 16 او
المقاتله السويديه صعب لان هذه الطائرات
القتاليه ستصنع الفارق بين انتهاء الحرب
او استمرارتها
[موسيقى]